people living in the village of bakla
take visitors here they say gas flaring
from oil production
decimated their generations old palm
trees
leaving behind nothing but trunks
when we met the village elders they said
everyone knows someone who is diagnosed
with
or who has died from cancer
i already have cancer and only god helps
me we continue to be worried about our
families and loved ones
the busra health department in southern
iraq says the pollution from oil
production
is making people and animals in the area
sick the iraqi high commission for human
rights says
due to the high rate of cancer in basra
it's demanding
the government work with oil companies
to combat pollution
there is no stability for six or seven
years every two years there is some
challenge political challenge security
challenge
gas is long-term investment it needs
some stability
and it needs some cash and commitment
the world bank ranks iraq number two
behind russia
when it comes to gas flaring instead of
polluting the air
the gas could be recovered and sold or
used to generate electricity
for millions of people
the busper gas company is investing 3
billion dollars to do
just that at the ramela oil field iraq's
largest anything that the iraqi
government can do
or its neighbours can do to create in a
stable environment is is good
for capturing more gas and for creating
a better
environment for the iraqi people the
people of bahrain say the land their
families have been tied to
for 200 years is toxic
and they wonder how many more of them
will get sick
before the government can help them
natasha ghanim
al jazeera basra iraq